what bats come with me Josh Smith and
today this special edition of Ready
Steady you teamed with my James Chuck
the real Queen is finally come to London
town listening act watch out
today you were gonna give me a little
bit yeah which I'm buzzing for you're
gonna pitch this range in kind of like a
QVC style way yeah how do you stand it
top line well this is the James
Charlesworth your artistry palette and
also the James Charles next working
brush that dinner currently still that
road might even if you wanted to get it
you cut it
sign still the limit I am so not hit me
let's get going okay I want you to tell
me like what were your favorite colors
in here so I want to give you a sister
James makeover I feel like I want to get
blazed and want my baby please - Paul
okay we love that okay so I'm gonna do
some blue love Atlanta but I gonna start
you off with some more orange ego or the
the crease region and like build it down
yeah what kind of for me the queen of
brows like this was a cool piece of
architecture on your face is that how
can we cheat our way just making your
brows blank feel like like a good
product is always where they go my first
thing love the vamos hacia bro it just
takes a lot of practice like when I
first started to make up three years ago
my brows were disgusting and they're
really eight inches thick
and it took a whole lot of love they
were beefy and I took a whole lot of
hate comments and a lot of tweezers
later to realize oh I should probably
fix these and now I love that so I'm
going to pick up that work the Emma for
four months just feeling kind of bigger
process brush yeah
James and a little one was great and to
top last if you just say you took a lot
like he comments to change the eyebrows
yeah when you see these paint comments
on YouTube how do you deal with them and
how do you stop yourself from taking
them on and I eventually realize like
the bigger you get and the harder you
work the more people are going to be
either tell that your suggest or does
not like you because people idea that a
not reduce modeling because I know they
also were going through like the crisis
of masculinity moment right yeah like
masculinity stick on basic reforms like
people that you were showing a new form
of masculinity and how okay that is all
right dick this is a man in 2019 guys
get with the program like how do you how
much the journey you go on with your
masculinity from when you were like
younger to now yeah so when I was
growing up I've always been
unapologetically myself like you know
when I was 12 my mom's talking I will
say having a strong sense of who I am
has really helped me to be able to help
others yes mm-hmm
because you have such an amazing
community around you yes this dish shout
out to the sisters yeah so what message
would you want to install in there a
positive mental mantra you'd want to get
there what every day ride yeah I think
like the one thing I'd be telling she'll
just like be yourself and that was do a
makeup channel but it's very important
to me that I tell everybody blaming me
you don't need make-up to be beautiful
and that's like my biggest
I wear makeup as a part form and to
express myself feel like you will never
see me walking out of the house in the
morning with a full face on like because
I need to feel confident not know what
has been the biggest beauty regret VA
that you've been the hognose the
eyebrows do you think nothing now you
think is there something even never day
oh I guess like there's a lot able to do
their eyebrows before their foundation
remember stop just wait watch works if
we get given a cheat sheet you have to
be more yay
what will go on it what bigger top 5
things I'd like a good moisturizer soft
with a super super fine home next would
be like any really good like kind of
medium coverage foundation because I'm
not doing a thinner full coverage
I'm gonna be a super great product so
like I said I saw see you want you can
just kind of sculpt it out and make it
look really nice and layer it up then
it'd be the climate change hauls
market palette because you can do it all
usually done for number five I'm just
say like I've been something is great
really long it in all day probably a
machine aqua palette which is a metallic
kind of navy blue color and then I went
to give it a little bit of a spread just
looks really cool she's good to go so
she's good to go we're gonna pop this
right on top I'm so intrigued to see
this how would you sum up this look
right now what's divine blue
shades we use in the lid just kind of
blue I mean we hit with popular Picasso
a cool metallic icy blue in color
and I use that on the inner corner next
acapella instead of just like you want
on the blue just add some more dimension
to the highway
how did you come up with names so all 39
games are like something that if they
can point to me in my life so we have
James boys get it together how do you
die it's not like you decide to go on an
app is it Oh every time I do my can't
get believe it because I never cashed
evens actually me but what's stupid is
like I don't want to like put the limit
it's not going to get reported to play
connect my answer what do you think is
the biggest lesson you've learned from
Ken I think the biggest thing for person
how does just like Bob Carol people say
right where we got to now pretty much
clean up this bad boy I'm gonna use now
face which is the highlighter shade in
the palette just a little under Bravo
moisturizing hydrating of the baby
please pumping that's the key thing okay
great that's why I want to know about a
plan that's your other people okay just
look don't stop me in the eyeball I
promise
yeah problems ten tests the tight tiny
the best eyebrow sunset yeah oh my god
these babies are gonna pop whoa nice day
for a real one
watch out London you have risen me thank
you so much love it I'm so Brady hi this
stuff like pop music collaboration
coming out saying fingers well just like
a lethal strike rice that's like a job
yeah trying yeah try and three pull wake
up eggs this is the ticket
[Applause]
[Music]